it's a tumor okay that's what Bret
Weinstein said about evergreen hmm you
know you know what the evergreen story
and him and all that no tell me about it
they did so there was a there was a day
of protest where all the black students
would leave okay every year to show you
what would be like without them and then
one then one year they said now this
year we want all the white people to
leave okay and Bret Weinstein apparently
said in like an email we shouldn't you
know if you want to choose to do
something you can do it yeah you can't
tell someone else what they should do so
they called him you know white
supremacists had not seen all this stuff
he ended up him and his wife ended up
losing their jobs really yeah as of that
yep yeah I think he's right though and
he was like Ana he's like an ultra
progressive he's like super hippie
progressive dude yeah and he tweeted
about this now that like my camera board
is referencing it might have been the
New York Times mm-hmm he was like what
happened at Evergreen was a tumor that
could have been cut out but now it's you
know a full grown movement asta sized or
whatever yeah and now it's everywhere
the the editor from the New York Times
resigning because he published an
opinion of a senator this is this is of
a sitting senator yeah a sitting senator
who literally said hey I want to do this
thing
here's what I want to do it and they
were like don't publish that it's
harmful and the creepy thing about it
man the creepiest thing about what's
going on is that apparently some
organization like the ACLU or something
I don't want to accuse them if it wasn't
them they argued that it was a workplace
safety issue therefore they were
protected in protesting over the story
amazing they wanted to defend an
ideology so they argued that it was
putting black New York Times employees
in harm's way somebody planned that out
for them somebody told them this is how
you get a story you don't like removed
claim it threatens a minority and makes
the workplace unsafe you know all of the
stuff that's happening it's just fishy
there's every single story is something
fishy about it so all the simulations
broken bro where well what about that
little bit that doesn't make any sense
and people have been hitting me up
non-stop for the pipe you mean rasmussen
reporting that trumps favorable rating
among the black community is 40% at the
same time race riots are breaking out
right or like stories came out a few
months ago claiming that Democrats will
never win an election again because
Trump's approval rating broke 20% then
all of a sudden we get all this and they
started calling Donald Trump racist and
then you think well you know these
things have been happening for a long
time so then Donald Trump makes a
tribute to George Floyd and the Twitter
deletes it yeah and then it's like well
then they and not only that they miss
like represented what he actually said
you know oh he be looking down and be
proud of the jobs that we brought back
and like yep he did not say that he
didn't he literally said we need to be
treated equally under the law right and
I think today is a good day and you know
George what would look down and I note I
think it is hmm there's a lot of really
dumb people who can't understand complex
thought and that's why they don't know
they don't know what a joke is for real
so it's like these people who think you
know edgy jokes are literal hate speech
or violence it's because their brains
can't process one plus one equals two
yeah it's like well there's a kind of a
weird Segway because he wasn't joking at
all it wasn't a joke but no no what I do
agree with you I think you're absolutely
right well the reason I bring that up is
Trump was talking about jobs mmm he then
started talking about George flow in the
protest yeah somebody who understands
complex ideas would easily understand
the context of him saying we all must be
treated equally under the law
so I think you know hopefully George
looking is you know he's looking down
and saying it's a great it's a great day
for him and for everyone yeah the people
who are too stupid go but he's talking
about jobs
oh why would George Floyd like jobs oh
my god probably so dumb hmm you take a
look at the you know the acid wash thing
during 2016 debate yeah it's my favorite
one yeah Donald Hillary Clinton did not
use a corrosive substance on her server
no not that no they did these people
their brains don't work so do you think
they really think it I think people in
media didn't think it but I think a
bunch of people saying home were like
the Hillary Clinton put acid on her
computer Trump so dumb why would he
think that well the fact that there
needed to be a fact check on it was like
okay obviously there's some people that
were looking it up like did she real
do that pour acid remember remember when
Nancy Pelosi put them on ripped up the
speech for Trump yeah so bad I think was
Babylon B who wrote this write about
ripping up the Bible yes yeah yeah so
Trump holds the Bible and then Babylon B
wrote beveling B is so good they really
are so I crack up almost every day they
took the picture of her ripping and put
a Bible and then said like you know to
defy Trump's photo-op of the Bible but
people are so dumb they were like Nancy
Pelosi ripped the Bible and you know
what the mess-up thing is it wasn't just
left wingers it was like right and left
was everybody on Twitter being like I
can't believe she would really do this
the simulation is broken man funny
enough though I could kind of believe it
the Bible clearly hates Trump I know I
don't I know yeah it's you ripped it up
it's like you didn't have to rip it up
well it's making a statement and what
you hate Trump like Cleavon we do have
this this this segment literally about
Babylon let's talk about it yeah take a
look at this clever church goers avoid
arrest by disguising themselves as
rioters now when we all saw this story
we all laughed yeah you understand the
joke it's very simple churches aren't
allowed to reopen yeah but they told the
protesters it was okay so this was this
was June 1st here it says June 1st so
it's actually really I don't wanna read
through the whole story but they it's
really funny they basically say like
churchgoers were outside smashing
windows and faking fighting each other
so that no one could know one will
realize they're actually worshiping the
Lord and then like inside I could see
them like wrestling and wrestling and
then they're like oh so here's what ends
up happening community north carolina
auto race draws thousand after dumping
itself a protest no this is not the
first time the babylon b has come true
it needs to stop dude and the onion is
as well and it's it's
yeah they're starting to get closer and
closer to the nose
I think this story is like they very
well may have seen the Babylon being
been like that's a good idea yeah
honestly yeah but but to be honest I
think a lot of people had the same idea
yeah I think I said something like how
long until someone just claims their
protest I mean do you have that that
picture from the from the news können of
which fox or CNN and we're just saying
like look you know the black like the
the Cova Dec spurts say yeah you know
going out and protesting for black lives
matter is okay it's not at risk but
don't confuse that with going out to
protest the the lockdown they basically
said we do not condemn the black lives
matter protest right this should not be
mistaken as a permission for the anti
lockdown protests and it's like wait
what I over to partisan support of
protests and then the craziest thing man
is there like but racism is the was the
virus all along that's what I find
really hilarious like everybody pointed
out on Twitter they're like the
Democrats are really going with the real
virus was the white supremacy we met
along the way like mom yeah no dude it's
a viruses and so now we're some data
came out like oh yeah he'll be the same
thing covert spiking a ton of flan is it
is it spiking yeah yeah yeah second wave
the Democrats are we're warning us about
it right now but here's the thing are
these people saying oh no because of the
protests bill de blasio was like I can't
understand why it's happening so weird
so strange three so here's gonna happen
when the second wave comes you know
these people aren't gonna say they're
not gonna say we should have protested
they're gonna say oh gotta trump you
anything if he didn't die we wouldn't
have been protesting so I wouldn't have
gotten the kovat they they don't get
that complex they're just not that smart
so what letter is gonna happen is
they're gonna ignore it like dude you
know what man I I have to I have to
believe that I often say
I don't think there's somebody sitting
behind the scenes like twirling their
mustache going yeah I'm going to destroy
the world but I got to say I think brian
Stelter Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon mm-hmm
they probably all sit around with
gigantic Joker smiles at the end of the
jazzmin they all go go into their
smoking room and take their faces off
put them on the shelf and their lizard
to keep them in good shape Noah like
this this story about the faking of
protests is clearly in response to the
establishment promoting ideological ends
and depressing the opponents of that and
there was a why should they have to do
this there was an opponent of the
governor there that was making a speech
someone someone hit me up on Twitter I
haven't seen any articles about it but
he had a whole speech about look like we
got a we got to go out and vote and get
this crazy Democrat out of out of the
office so we can continue our lives take
a look at this one we ran governor
Cooper says state will take action
against NC Speedway that continues to
draw thousands you kidding me dude
they're threatening a business but these
people can go out and they'll march
shoulder-to-shoulder yeah yeah dude that
so look I really mean it I don't I don't
I think I wonder if brian Stelter cries
himself to sleep at night I'm not even
kidding
cuz I met him a long time ago and I
don't think he's a bad guy but now he's
in a contract with CNN he's in this life
he can't give it up we know Chris Cuomo
faked his quarantine definitely confirms
job yep and he hates his job yeah Don
Lemon Cuomo hates his job yeah yeah he
went on his own rate he went on his
radio show he was like I can't stand
what I do I find no value in this I
don't want to do this so how is it that
you know two days ago brian Stelter is
tweeting you know about Trump violating
CDC guidelines and social distancing
then a day later he's like these
protesters they're expressing real
frustration blah blah blah if you're out
protesting you hate old people that's
that's what they were they were you're
killing me you're killing grandma for a
month and a half I heard that I'm sorry
man at this point their brains must be
like ripping in half I wonder if like
after every show his I like just goes in
the wrong direction a little bit I'm
like like I needs like hold on one
second because like his brain gets it
back
well like the cognitive dissonance is so
palpable yeah that like he's sitting
there reading and that was part of half
his brains
like it's like he just snaps in like
yeah and so well because like his brain
is trying to reconcile to two things
that cannot be true at the same time
right so he knows I think he knows and
that's why I would say at this point I
really do consider him to be kind of
like a mustache truly you know he knows
what he's doing you know there's no way
I tweeted I tweeted something mocking
one of the protest signs I can't breathe
and I said I can't breathe as an
unfortunate thing to put on a protest
sign considering a week from now they
won't be able to do two kovin I see and
I love it somebody that's spicy
well spicy ones but I was I was making a
point right so I and didn't it to
actually disproportionately affect the
black community yes somebody responded
man I I tweeted out like a week ago I
was like it feels like the Democrats
want the second wave to hit this
population it's like I don't understand
they're like you know go protest go
protest it's like what haven't we been
locked down haven't isn't this virus
like super deadly shouldn't we protect
our citizens against this oh no you're
you're encouraging them to go protest
like our hoo-hoos whose side are exactly
my side are you on are you kidding me
like I'm here I'm worried about these
people because there's a lot of people
out there that are actually peacefully
protesting and they have every right to
do that and they're gonna get sick yeah
exactly ANSI Pelosi is sitting in that
in that Capitol building twirling her
mustache that that makes the most sense
to me yeah she probably has a mustache
under underneath the mask I think he
talks like sounds like this I think your
wife she's talking on TV break I can't
stand listening to her because she's an
idiot he scares me
yeah but anyway the point I was making I
put that tweet out and somebody
responded yet here's what you thought
about the anti lockdown protesters and
it was like a bunch of my tweets where I
was like the fascists are trying to stop
the protest or whatever and I was like
what in my tweet about the sign has
anything to do with support or
opposition for the protests right I saw
I completely support the black lives
matter protest and I thought so in like
a dozen videos absolutely I don't
support the riding in the looting
exactly and I think there's a double
standard in allowing them to protest and
complain with the other ones right but I
think everybody should protest whether
there's a pandemic
not give me liberty or give me death
it's in our Constitution they to protest
if we feel the need peaceably assemble
yes but they have this caricature is a
ssin of what's happening and and the
crazy thing is whenever I see the memes
they're not really means but they're
like you know snapshots and Twitter
posts from the left on Facebook they
never seem to get real conservative
personalities or moderate personalities
it's always like Joe Bob 53 with like a
picture of a duck for his avatar okay
and then he's like I think daggum Donald
Trump got a boo-boo or whatever and they
like post a picture and they're like oh
look how dumb these conservatives are
and I'm like try a tweet from ben
shapiro yeah you can deal manning that
one yeah you can criticize ben shapiro
for sure yeah but if you go to if you go
to his Twitter if you go something like
Crowder you'll see them making
legitimate points yeah exactly they
don't they don't want legitimate points
they fax cancel cancel that that's why
they have good news mob power you guys
you know I guess that's where the power
truly lies well that didn't work for
Bernie Sanders didn't nope like he was
pandered to the a certain community and
lost all of his followers basically well
they never followed him the first place
in my opinion so oh yeah but I mean were
you ever like a die-hard like what
you're walking around the Bernie shirt
and like waving signs or anything I I
did I supported him 2016 oh yeah I was I
I liked Bernie back then I don't know I
didn't this this round you know what man
young people like a lot of the people I
know you know even some of my family
members I are just unfortunately really
dumb this guy I knew growing up was
posting on Facebook saying that I needed
to get back to my roots and stuff like
that and I don't understand what's going
on and I'm like bro the progressive
activists are overwhelmingly white
college-educated upper middle-class
families yeah you think I have anything
to do with those people I've never had
anything that I we talking about we're
both on the south side of Chicago who
are you defending these upper crust
college kids who have trust funds right
it's not all of them but it's a lot of
them and not only that I sent him a
video and I'm like you know he started
complain what if they post it and I'm
like did you watch it you know I don't
need to there it is there it is
you just believe whatever it is you're
told and you don't care
actually read or research or do anything
and then you March like lemmings off a
clip off a cliff really dude NPC really
nails nail that these people are and do
not care about your statistics or your
facts I'm gonna believe what I want to
believe my feelings feelings my believe
might be said I know what's true I feel
what's true yes he does he doesn't know
anything and it was really funny because
uh when I went on Crowder he asked me
when I had that moment where I was like
all of a sudden I wanted a second
amendment whatever and I said actually
it was uh yeah it was a build up over
boys but it was really simple actually
it was a couple years ago I had done a
video where I was explaining I think
there's reasonable restrictions on oh
yeah or whatever yeah yeah and the top
builder LEDs the top comment was a guy
saying like I completely agree I would
love to have some restrictions on your
right to speech and I went oh no no no
I'll keep my speech you keep your guns
yep this story we gotta meet that guy
but it's well it's some truth though for
sure but you want to limit my rights
then I get to limit your rights it's
like then we just start getting in this
battle of like then we have no rights
exactly everybody's now now like okay
I'll take this one is like a strategy
gamers rather keep all the rights that
we have but a lot of people point out
that that's like it's unfortunate most
most people the overwhelming majority
can't understand that concept
yeah and like I got hit by some friends
and they were like they were like you
know that was that was that showed you
to be very very smart that you
immediately recognized the logical break
and what you're proposing unified it you
recognized and changed your mind
newsflash people you can do that but it
wasn't even can change your mind it
wasn't here knowledge that you didn't
know previous and your mind will expand
it wasn't even about necessarily new
information either it was just an
argument and my mind is open to
arguments I haven't considered yeah and
if it connects the logical pathways
properly then I accept it it's this
that's it but people don't do that
it's fun cognitive dissonance they
actively reject any new information
coming in you know if they refuse to
watch because they know I was reading
about this cuz I I've mentioned several
times I used to you know hang out with
like hackers and stuff and very much
into social engineering and what I read
was that when people are around the age
of 24 that's when your mind start
it's like solidifying mm-hmm in terms of
like you're growing up your learning
your mind is open to what the brain
actually is continuously growing until
around that age exactly
so make sense so when I was reading is
that the the and I'm not an evolutionary
psychologist was really like one book I
was reading so I'm sure a bunch of
evolution evolutionary psychologists
could easily correct me but what they
said was basically this the human mind
has a need to stop accepting new
concepts or ideologies around a certain
age hmm because you've survived this
long and to maximize your potential for
survival you are the survivor by the
time you reach adulthood and you're an
adult male or female or whatever modes
worked so far exactly interesting so
then your brain shuts down and says this
is what we need to protect because this
worked and we lived right that way so
what happens then is when someone comes
and presents information that would
force your brain to unlock and reassess
it's a threat that could rip that could
end your life so people have violent
reactions as an animalistic nature
exactly the general idea is that
explains a Hall of Carens all the
Karan's out there yeah
new information would so what I read was
in response to information that
contradicts their long-standing
worldview people start to immediately
get angry as a defense mechanism and
then people who are forced to finally
accept it undergo a mental breakdown a
complete mental breakdown panic attacks
collapse I ability to work I mean I see
it all the time in a lesser version
because of me being vegan it's like
anytime anyone even hears that I am
suddenly there's a trigger that they
need to like convince me why it's okay
they still eat meat I'm like whoa I
don't I don't care what you eat why why
are we still talking about this ten
minutes later like whap please I don't
care what you eat you know it's really
thought that what what I find funny and
this is the inversion of the old trope
where it's so we bought some oat milk
right right and it said on it how it
says how do you know if someone's vegan
don't worry they'll tell you yeah that
used to be what it is right right but
now it's the other way around where like
whenever whenever it comes up with like
our friends someone will be like so
Adams vegan by the way that I was like I
didn't say anything dude
don't freak it out hi yeah and then the
response was vegan talking about food
what a surprise I was like okay did you
not hear what they Tim said Italy hello
I I'm just sitting in the corner eating
my food leave me alone but uh but anyway
no right I think it's funny though I
think you do bring up a good point
people immediately have to defend their
view yeah everything but it's that the
same reason it's it's rooted in a place
in their brain that is it's there it's
an emotional response they're there
you're attacking my way of life oh I
must just by simply being different and
that in itself looks like look beyond
the vegan thing you know open it up to
everything that's literally what it is
it's an animalistic response to being
attacked and that's why food is really
easy
like that's trample yeah because there's
this keto people there's low-carb people
there's beef only people and you know
what people good for them right
that's what I say good for them have
have at it do whatever you want to do
but I will defend your right to eat
whatever you want I have had vegans like
a brigade my video trust me I've known
some of these videos and I can't stand
them
it's like you you can't force an
ideology down someone's throat and then
have them like suddenly be like you know
what alright I'll be vegan it's like
that's great that's never gonna happen I
went vegan of my own volition I would
never expect anyone to just become vegan
it's like shut up and eat whatever you
want I don't care I don't care it's like
yeah I care about animals and yeah it's
like sure we can talk about it if you
want to if you want to but if you don't
that's fine with me too that's cool eat
what you want and now think about how
this plays into politics with people
like you know we were driving around and
we saw one of these black lives matter
protests and I could only think phonetic
like the way they looked their signs
made no sense I don't even know what
they were what they were saying yeah and
I know what would happen I've tried to
talk to these people okay like that
actually we referenced this earlier the
Brent Brandon strike video where he goes
to a black had a protest he starts
talking and the woman just screams and
flicks him off and tells him he's dumb
and stuff like that that's exactly it
you know but so in terms of protest it's
actually really easily exemplified they
have a social group humans are social
animals that rely on each other for
survival yeah so adherence to the social
rule
and social norms is paramount for a
survival if that is challenged the
outsider must be purged you must defend
your group
humans are tribalistic facts don't care
about your feelings and you know one
another thing is we've talked about this
a little bit it's like how the human
race wasn't ready for social media and
and that really is it we're social
animals so we're not used to
communicating socially in person anymore
now it's all done online the the nuances
of the way we speak the the energy we we
give off when we're speaking to it's
like that's lost that yeah you know now
it's just this digital you know text
essentially and you talk everything's
gone
jokes yeah meaningless right all right
no one everyone's taking everything
literally it's it's crazy you know so we
need to I always say this we need to do
this and I hate saying that because I
don't know the answers you know I I'd
like to think that I want to open a
conversation with people but just saying
that we need to do this we need to have
a conversation boom people are triggered
yeah you're trying to tell me what to do
you're trying to you have all the
answers huh hmmm it's like no I'm I
don't that's why it's it's it's really
just tribes yeah like I was mentioning
this in Northern Ireland we talked about
this right like yeah this wall in one
side just they just oppose each other
and whatever they say yeah I mean we're
saying here anything Trump says it's
like nope I'm believe the dead opposite
this is where I think people like Brian
Southers head will eventually explode
because right
you can they they're really trying to
justify why they're allowed to protest
yeah and it doesn't work it doesn't make
any sense and so it's like yeah it's
like I mentioned the other day the train
tracks are slowly splitting off left and
right it's on a fork it's one track
going left one track going right trains
gonna just fly off and crash yeah so you
can't be a good way of putting it yeah
someone said oh well the right wing and
the left wing there it's the same bird I
was like damn it's like we're all humans
yeah it's a train with two tracks that's
really a good way to put it it's just
gonna it's just gonna crash well but
what I mean is if brian Stelter is going
say Trump isn't social distancing that
track is going to the left and if he
says protesters are good that checkers
going to the right your train eventually
just flies off because the tracks are
yeah it makes no sense in their
desperate attempts to always think Trump
is wrong they have now made themselves
completely incoherent yeah it's it's
freaky it and really is so Biden
actually would be a good leader for them
yes he makes no sense
exactly he's in the coherent he's
totally coherent actually so they're in
white.i just their universe is like a
Picasso painting okay and everything's
just like nothing makes sense and
there's like cars are flipping over and
driving backwards and and they're their
eyes are like different directions well
maybe they think it's more of like a
Monet and that you're like you really
just have to keep backing up and really
get the big picture and know that Samuel
understands everything only wanna like
for us you know you want to back up and
what if you look close and it doesn't
make any sense so that's really blows em
for them yeah I mean they're like their
worldview is a Picasso and ours is just
like I don't know Rembrandt whatever
like a normal looking painting yeah you
know I don't know you know I'll just
reference that name yeah Sam thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you